the return is that raffa the industry europeans
we must
not succumb to the temptation to return to
national action in the refugee
crisis
right now we need more europe
we need more than ever the courage
and cohesion in europe has always shown exactly
when it matters they
represent  in your function the
old europe that has failed our crisis
is a in the styling from march appearing
pasmanns an nils the motto easy street
station
if you want to create trust
within the european union
in your ability to act then you have to
come back to what was
left behind  is as far as the stability of the
common currency is concerned the world
is not waiting for our internal
debates
that is why europe must move
forward with
commitment kelek arise thursday on shear zones
the dialect of unity in
europe